we have warzone kings this is a war zone
rated one minute time control 56
gladiators have entered with an average
rating of 1859 time handicap 30 minutes
of fast chests coming up the black ninja
I think this guy is up there with the
assassin and by that I mean fear fear
the black ninja without a doubt if you
are not fearing the black ninja you
should let's go here 96 no let's get
this guy out before pot so I could get
punished in real quick before my
opponent threatens this advance I don't
think it's good right now let's back up
this is not gonna be a quick kill let's
get this Night Out pressure on here
more pressure hang on oh it's scary it's
very scary and I have to give up the
exchange maybe I thought if Knight
played there right away but there's no
there's no issue right now although I am
winning upon am I not take here with
tempo I'm the queen my queen is
centrally placed I might want to just
take that night out and then you'd land
a fork or I might not
let's do this there's no need to take
that Knight he's not bothered musi don't
take pieces that aren't bothering you oh
these are just wonderful suggestions
aren't they don't take pieces that are
not bothering you okay let's run away if
you're scared that's another one ah
wonderful rules of thumb run away if
you're scared run away if you're scared
okay I could I could have landed a fork
here let's come here I'm not afraid of
doubled uh doubled pawns you could turn
out to be a thorn you could be a thorn
knight here watch out for Knight there
let's watch over this my knight is
unprotected fourteen seconds each the
Knights gonna hit my bishop right here
back up it's scary it's very scary
get the King position going get this
rook out of here are they in pins
they're in Forks take that pawn you know
you want to take the pawn they didn't
take the pond
okay anything clock situation anything -
down on time back to chairman -
everybody has to everybody has to this
guy has to Oh tough guy
uh Oh French defense winter water winter
war it is gonna chop gonna play here
gonna play queenie - gonna castle gonna
throw my rook on d1 that's the plan i
don't know what that mo is doing what's
that move doing oh oh watch out for
sneakiness Queen takes here Queen takes
pawn is not good ah man I got to do this
if I push there's Queen takes pawn width
check I don't have the sneaky Bishop
takes pawn let's back up I want to watch
over this square let's get there
this pawn is this Knights dead my
position is crumbling or is it let's get
that rook out of there and get out of
there look and stay right here bishop
you know you're doing a good job by
being there they want to try I don't
want to draw they're doing good to get
rid of my bishop let's keep my bishop
right here he's got to be a pest
keep your pieces in a pest formation
keep your pieces in the pest formation
wow you're really doing good here really
doing good there okay let's do this rook
up and over everybody loves a rook up
and over don't try to get active rook
don't you dare okay my rook wants to do
something else like run to the corner
and then give checks to the King the
king wants to be here
the Knights gonna be here and that's
scary and I can't protect them or I'm a
dead man let's try this I'm giving up
that pound though
scariness is the night trapped ooh the
night might be trapped no he's not
let's come over here clock situation how
we doing once again as soon as I'm down
as soon as I'm beat I look right to the
clock clock save me pin on the night pin
that night give a check give another
check just for fun
kick the rook around the rook is close
to trap but not o sneakiness there down
on time back to tournament 1616 for once
again the black ninja this guy does not
go into the night quietly here oh it's
always a struggle this is only my second
time playing them but I'm assuming it's
always gonna be a difficult road ahead
why don't I just take that pot and then
land a check right here that would have
been beautiful
Oh quick resigned they missed that they
missed that one didn't they hit the
Queen pre-move are they in a pre move
let's go hit this Knight a little bit
more or the Queen I'm on the Queen
they're not resigning turn my ipod up
there 85 84 I open up the a file let's
go with check King up he's safe here
isn't he I just dropped a piece get him
get him Knight Supreme of that that
wasn't a good pre move oh they're giving
it back Oh check I should have done with
the Queen the Queen would have been me
ah right here I have to re-earn it you
have to relearn it now on that rook
watch out for me this is gonna be a rook
check oh this is me the rook move just
move just moved back to tournament 1212
back to term in 26 1210
okay 24 minutes remaining a lot of time
a lot of time anything could still
happened this guy right here the guy in
second is the one that I was talking
about before the tournament kicked
let's try some gambit maybe Scotch
gambit is the night gonna play there
let's see what happens Bishop c5 c3 and
then tricks on f7 main line main line d5
Bishop here night here Knight takes pawn
bishop takes this and castle I want to
get this night away I'm okay with
doubled pawns because I have this
supported I want to get rid of the dark
square Bishop I also want to get my
majority rollin I have a four on three
on the Kings side let's get going pawn
push night here I almost just dropped my
bishop let's just drop my bishop there
don't drop your bishop
no there's trouble my knight is in a pin
and it's get kicked away and I might be
getting kicked away again and then again
let's do this and I want to back up my
dark square Bishop serious problems
could happen any moment any moment
what's the clock okay the knight is in a
pin but on a good square if he's kicked
away the bishop looks silly age three
King age to get off of this diagonal I
have this covered I think I'm in a good
spot I don't want to trade too much I
think staying right behind this okay
let's do this opposite color Bishop
ending who can get their Bishop more
active that's the big question who could
get it more active I should have done
this and I'm gonna do it now and I'm
gonna do this next I'm okay if that pawn
falls I think Oh am i I know I shouldn't
have let it fall no that's okay I'm
gonna do this and then come back then I
want Targ at this point right here
making one if the Queen goes too crazy
she gonna go crazy I have this square
escape hatch I want to just get to where
right here rook to g3 pressure serious
pressure sneakiness I have this diagonal
covered against my king I'm not sure
what that rook love is doing I wanted to
play here and here it was covered though
clock count clock count let's just do
anything no time back to tournament 20
whoa 52 somebody has seven games in cap
52 points wow it looks like a battle for
second place
we're only nine minutes into this I
think I would need to be paired up with
cap twice in be lucky enough to win
twice or or I could hook that worm hook
the worm it should be seven hook the
worm variation go fish
go fish okay there's no fishing over
here on the Kings side the king is not
over there no fishing allowed over here
oh let's try this my Knights gonna keep
it around but I get this rook the bishop
needed to play their first I'm okay with
doubled pawns I want to get my bishop
here I'll go after the Queen it's too
scary this square right here so let's
let's not let sacrifices happen clean
trade I guess or yeah I was gonna be
sneaky with this so I could get the rook
but that's not happening get that night
out of here maybe night here I go here
let's do that no I'm gonna do this maybe
the knight is trapped if it uh there's a
queen trade trap tonight variation trap
night it's a trap night it's a cook
tonight cook tonight he's cooked okay I
think it's all good now
is it all good just block I don't want
to recapture okay right here bishop here
next I'm on the bishop I got the rook
I'm gonna be up a rook keep the pinned
pieces my opponent disconnected ah like
the sight of a pin there like I've had
it
let's exit out of this site this is the
time reversal I'm playing it's the time
reversal and they're burning their time
back to tournament 3075 is in first 10
games Wow Pascal 34 somebody needs to
knock off kappa rot somebody needs to
knock off that top guy oh hang on that
power moved a second time I make use of
data temple us King side castle Queenie
one Queen g3 f5
okay let's do this pawn push ninety-four
okay there's no time for that
what about pawn push Knight f4 and also
just have this stuff opened up at palm
push Knight f4 Oh pins everywhere it's
gonna be a capture there is open file
keep the pin clean check I have that
covered I'm on this as well keep
pressure on this night
maybe there's something like on this
square I think I just want to take let's
just take here it seems right somehow
I'm on the Queen I'm on the bishop the
the Queen key of check here should get
checked there that was the that was the
move to be running with the king is in a
giant pickle giant pickle there's gonna
be a check on the King I think this is
correct first give a check there's gonna
be a queen giving a check she's not
giving a check that's me
or is it it's not me it's really close
to me oh no I have this rook move this
is leading to me
yes these guys control these two squares
the naica block or the Queen no matter
what this that's me back to term at 42
huh what a mountain I have to climb 95
points in first 18 minutes remaining
Jonathan c5 we have been here before we
have definitely been here before
get that night out of there okay okay if
the knight took the pond I had Queen
over here if they took on c5 more
development in castle Bishop out I want
this file to open up just take here I'll
there on my bishop throw my bishop
where's the mate night here Queen check
I dropped a piece where's the mate
they're in a pin it's not really working
is it
let's hang on hang on hang on hang
give a check I don't want to trade
cleans quit trying to trade Queens let's
come here Knight here is probably good
ah ah okay get this take that pun you
know you want to take that pun they're
threatening mate I almost fell for it
they're they're trying to fishing pull
me don't try the fishing pole on me
please they reserved they're just giving
me the win 115 the black ninja again the
black ninja is everywhere at every
corner the black ninja is like you
cannot get rid of me so easily
no you won't get rid of me so easily
I am wherever you look I am wherever you
looks as the black ninja okay let's grab
this pond and hang on to it for dear
life oh it's gonna look ugly over here
with the structure ugly structure later
grab that part and support the night
no don't support the night you'll weaken
this square doing this is fine that's
what you meant to do that's what you
meant to do oh I'm Queen f4 tricky stuff
this Knight needs to go somewhere Knight
here give a check let's do it anyhow
right here even though it's not gonna
wind stuff I need a flight square I'd be
nice flight squared time let's do this
support my knight I'd love to get a
piece right here I'll make that happen
my rook needs to do something else okay
it's ready to do something else oh I
just dropped a rook that was a good idea
the black ninja strikes it strikes come
on you can still do it be tricky with
that Knight be tricky with that Knight
be tricky with that Knight a mate
threatened to spots is it working it
might be working it might be working
it's working the tricky Knight variation
back to tournament the black ninja oh
why did I drop my rook like that I was
too excited about throwing a pig on the
second
look out 15 minutes 15 minutes remaining
this guy is not gonna move and he's not
gonna double the points either oh
there's the clock there is the clock we
are at Midway right here 15 minutes
remaining
and I don't even know if it's worthwhile
to do any homework 15 games 153 oh the
pack leader capper ah is saying no I
will not be caught you will have no hope
at the halfway point and that is just
what's happening serious pressure on f7
what's my game good looking like it's
looking pretty equal less than 20
seconds as well
h4 Oh tricky Knights bad stuff is about
to happen to black and there is a game
that I have to go back to okay less than
one second let's go let's go let's go
let's go back to term and 81 what are
the standings 153 81 90 or 79 I'm
fighting for second place
pretty head about first I think at first
15 games 153 that game is dead okay I'm
glad it's just not the black ninja
basically at this point anybody but the
black ninja 12
let's go with this oh they're going in
Reverse the night was clearly not too
good for his home right there on that
one Oh light squares take that power and
bad things happen give a check I'll go
here I'm okay I don't want a castle or
maybe I do move Knight he's not moving
I want to get rid of that Knight get rid
of that night oh let's do this I
wouldn't get that Queen out there get
out of there Queen get out of there
Queen you should close to trapped I want
to get that night I got the night the
Queen sneaking in h7 be very scared it's
amazing one unavoidable actually the
record have played here that was
avoidable for just a move or two 173 101
79 Wow 73 points gonna get 73 points
chess Skype says no if you're gonna get
any points you're gonna have to earn it
and that's not how you earn it you don't
earn it by making mouse slips oh I gotta
regroup here you have to regroup right
now throw your pawn in the pen make life
uncomfortable for white or you will take
a serious beating okay I'm getting a
pawn back or structural damage I'm
getting the pawn back and I think I want
to get rid of this guy because he's just
too good he's just too good of a bishop
and now they have this file and they
have pressure on this pawn but what else
could I do
I could pin a knight I get rid of that
tricky guy they're gonna get my knight
though they're gonna return the favor
pin my knight and say how do you like it
let's take here the arm winning stuff
I'm winning stuff I got from the
material mine on the I'm on the bishop
I'm up a full piece no I'm up a full
rook uh-oh are they gonna resign they're
down on time let's trade Queens they're
not resigning I could do this let's get
the looks off its throw a pig on the
second main - I have my back Lane
covered let's just be extra cautious
extra cautious I have this covered with
my clean I'm gonna take lateral movement
easily missed
upon coordination Queens off punt or
rook here
pigs get those pigs going right here
right here making one if they take the
rook they're not taking it okay the down
on tying back to determine 193 121 was
there a little slip-up there there might
have been a slip-up
Jonathan again efore for the win win a
water and okay let's go here I guess
that's a serious weakness the e6 pond is
gonna be targeted if there's Castle
there's Knight takes here Castle their
work into a pin there's Knight takes
pawn pile up on this guy he's pinned and
now he's hit twice zero defenders the
development is out I'm on the Queen
check where are the mates my mother up
there down there down 141 to 13 he must
have just won 213 141 119 this guy again
Sicilian let's not my lip this time
Queen c7 9 F 6
easy does it hang on Forks right around
the corner actually I had a fork I
should do that immediately and now it is
a fork would they resign right away
there's 10 minutes remaining
no kitchen sink I'm getting kitchen sink
I think 9600 kitchen sink kitchen sink
everywhere ok get the F file no don't
you do that yes it is clearly the
kitchen sink line
okay back to chairman 161 hang on hang
on it's a possibility over try my best
Oh 233 6 game lead Wow Lombardo's efore
d 4d 4f 4 9 mover it's a non mover and
the points aren't being doubled oh they
are doubled they are doubled we're gonna
see action
okay let's go here the Philidor defense
oh I should just snipped on this square
let's stop castling difficult to castle
hit the Queen chaser back home get
castled and i'm gonna take here i want
to open up this you're right here is
what I want to do hanging out of my
light square bishop on push the knight
is trapped
okay the Knights trap this was needed
but this is a tough spot no matter what
for that Knight knight c6 take Queen
here okay
let's go with this right here chase that
Queen away look for a quick mate
clean here I get the Queen let's take
here first that's not really working
sneaky stuff checks in two directions
pins also I got the Queen 32 time is
good I have to clean there in check
let's get this in right here Knight
right here
g6 coming to g6 landing landing pad
right there Forks clean infiltration I'm
on the rook discovered tricks but the
rook the bishop can't go too far the
bishop goes to d7 I give a check this is
me no it's not no it's not
ah it wasn't me let's just take care
that this game is not gonna end just
take here as well time burners time
burners time burners where are you at
okay they're down 181 253 181 it's not
happening could I keep second place at
least 70 points out from first 253
points is a lot all right
let's gain some space on the Queen side
let's play this capture as soon as that
pond pushes there it's not pushing there
though still gonna try for this I can
remove that night castle are they gonna
Castle oh they're fearing the a fishing
pool
let's do this Knight here would end up
losing a pond
let's just do this if the night takes I
want to just post in the center let's
now I'm trying to get here dark squares
no it's a mouse lip let's try this I'm
dropping this pawn let's try that and
then let's let's open this up here oh
let's do this I was gonna play here I
think the knight wants to take and then
this pawn can move or something I'm not
moving fast enough let's go here castle
and then do I do a pawn push now I want
this file to open up the king and queen
are on it just capture here let's try
this I need to open it up get rid of
that no I should just take in the
nightma taking this pawn let's try it
again with check and then take care
that's the idea
forks right here Knight f4 Knight check
leading to me run back here oh they gave
up the Queen 10 seconds I where's my
time where's my time I need time burners
where are they
I need a rook up look up and over time
burners where are you at where are you
at with the time burners just have to do
this oh oh oh oh five seconds what I
don't have any time oh come on throw in
some time burners time burners tricky
Knights tricky Knights tricky Knights
push up on right here give a check
they're gonna take time burners time
burners time burners go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go
can I get this can I get this please I
got it oh man David Blaine David Oh
anybody but the big bad wolf who's
holding my breath again submerge in that
tank Wolf Man resins that's the first
time that has
ever happened the king Cain
once again I thought this was kappa rot
right here oh man
just hold your breath that's all it's
gonna be okay it'll be okay just hold
their breath okay get out of there
sneaky bishop kick that bishop around
they're being sneaky back throwing in a
and in between her there I have this
square covered enough I want to get to
f4 that's why I didn't go here although
I could have went f6 and then there more
development pawn push maybe let's get
this night up here
okay the Queen's are gonna be coming off
and I think I like playing g5 here maybe
get the G file here G file King up in
the center there's no need to castle
right here knight in the center pawn
cannot be taken tricky checks oh this is
a problem this is a problem isn't it I
got the bishop my berries are they gonna
resign they're not residing right here
undermine this pawn Forks watch out for
those Forks that's ugly I don't want to
have to do that
if the knight moves okay we have this
from line a piece up okay coming up go
after the beep unsecure this Bishop's
position first then here and then okay
here that king is ready to get into mate
making to go here you know you want to
go here they don't want to go there okay
let's grab here time time time time
three minutes and change anything
anything just move any moves even if
you're losing pieces all right keep
going back to Turman 231 281 50-point
lead three minutes left I need three
quick wins in three minutes
it happens if it happens
it's gonna be crazy three quick wins
quick resign errs good it happened
mainline it's not gonna happen you're
lucky if you get this win and even have
another game finish its Castle okay this
no I want to do this similar situation
going on is that one game watch over
this Pawnee and then protect them clean
up my other rook to e1
that rook is very active and okay let's
guard upon that Bishop is a little too
close for comfort here get out of there
okay I gotta kick that bishop around
here get out of there Bishop you have no
business being there
come here I could take this guy
get out of there bishop ah the bishops
so annoying why isn't it getting out of
out of there get out of there Queen
we're gonna have a queen trade no we're
not time situation was guarding my
second rank watch out for the sneaky
Queen I gotta get this okay pigs right
here get the King up my dark square
Bishop is stupid stupid dark square
bishop okay
get right behind the pawn clock
situation where we at I'm gonna take
that pine put this in the king is
creeping over what a creepy case of
creepy crap look he's a creepy crawler I
don't have any time come on
don't you dare chase me away creepy
crawlers just take this okay get out of
there
I've gotta stop that I think and I don't
have any time do you realize I don't
have any time Oh everything's falling
can I sneak this in oh I got a clean I
got a queen I got a queen can I get this
I can't even look at my clock do I have
this do I have it I got a draw at least
oh my god I got a deserter I'm gonna
take that one that's a very important
one otherwise I would have been in third
right now and this guy could pass me off
at the last second oh I think that could
maybe help out with securing second
maybe first place is never happening
never happening can I possibly get
there's only 24 seconds hopefully that
guy is not ready to win I'm on the
bishop whoa done expecting what that one
what do we have is are they are they
calling it just call it just call it
just college just call it my nights
gonna get kicked away could I really get
here they're gonna allow me to get here
I want to get to eat three or g3 or h4
or anything right here right here and
then III what do we have what do we have
what do we have third you mutt it must
have just one right at the last second
oh man he beat that last guy right at
the end I guess ah so close good games
all 25 beefy games 321 259 251 187
Wolfman right up there